and when search Crews finally found the
children the good news went out by radio
as an alert one word repeated four times
Miracle the siblings were airlifted out
of the Jungle after being stranded for
more than five weeks the youngest barely
a year old the oldest just 13.
the father of the two youngest is
revealing heartbreaking details of what
happened he says Leslie the 13 year old
says their mother survived the crash but
was badly injured before she died she
told the children to leave to save
themselves
plane disappeared May 1st in the dense
Amazon jungle the pilot had radioed a
Mayday alert due to engine failure
more than 100 soldiers and 200
indigenous volunteers searched a massive
area about 300 square kilometers the
wreckage was found May 16th with three
bodies the children weren't there it's
believed they were in the back of the
plane when it crashed they survived
because that part was less damaged they
still had to survive the Jungle the
children's grandmother says they were
led by the 13 year old a young girl she
says with the nature of a warrior the
family are members of an indigenous
tribe the children were taught hunting
and fishing at a young age and also
played survival games and knew what they
could eat in the jungle and what was
poisonous
the father says the children are
recovering well he hopes to have his
kids back home soon now the youngest
child has a new Godfather the family has
given that honor to the commander of the
rescue operation it is amazing I just
only have one kid but for me I have in
this moment too
Operation HOPE isn't quite over during
the search the soldiers lost a dog in
the jungle Wilson is missing and the
military says it won't leave him behind
they're still looking this is a drawing
of Wilson done by one of the children in
hospital Mike Armstrong Global News